it's an announcement that's supposed to
help open the door for negotiations with
saudi arabia and other gulf arab states
lebanon's information minister george
kardashe's comments calling the war in
yemen a saudi aggression triggered the
worst deterioration in relations in
years for weeks kardashi rejected calls
to resign he now explains why he changed
his mind
french president emmanuel macron is
heading to saudi arabia on an official
visit what i understood from the prime
minister who i met three days ago is
that france wants to use my resignation
to help open dialogue with saudi arabia
french president emmanuel macron has
been urging gulf states not to isolate
lebanon it's believed he wants to use
the resignation as a bargaining chip to
convince saudi arabia and other states
to restore economic and diplomatic ties
with lebanon the government in beirut
right now is
basically a corporation where the french
and the iranians are called the shots
and it seems that for the government in
order to be able for it to succeed to in
order to be able for it to ensure the
implementation of the reforms that are
being asked for by the international
community there must be
some sort of an
involvement of
gulf money there is no guarantee the
resignation will be enough for saudi
arabia which has said it won't engage
with a government controlled by the
iranian-backed hezbollah but it could
help end the political crisis in lebanon
kardashian is backed by hezbollah which
along with its allies paralyzed the
cabinet for weeks they want the lead
judge investigating the 2020 explosion
at beirut port
bittar removed for what they allege is
political bias efforts to limit his
jurisdiction in the case are now
underway
prime minister najib who took office in
september promised to repair ties with
arab gulf states but it has been a
difficult balancing act with political
power in lebanon in the hands of
hezbollah there was a
problem that faced him mainly on the
system in lebanon and the political
system second what have taken place
between lebanon and the gulf and in this
period of time especially we need the
best scenarios in order to be uh healing
on
on the healing track a saudi ban on all
imports from lebanon is adding pressure
to an economy already in free fall a
gesture of goodwill may reverse such
measures but repairing a relationship
with a traditional ally is part of a
larger geopolitical struggle with iran
senator al jazeera beirut